I did get a chemistry set as a fairly as
a small kid and I tried it and found it
rather boring because all the
experiments were very safe and but then
I came across a book in the school
library and I'm guessing now that I've
reconstructed only a few days ago
because of the Nobel Museum for quest
for artifacts that this probably was
actually when I was only about eight
years old and it had some much cooler
experiments that were a little more
dangerous and required some corrosive
chemicals and things like that and
somehow maybe my father helped me get
some of them and I tried them and found
what they were really neat and so that
got me started doing experiments at home
in the basement which was sort of
worrying to my parents but they were
also a mixture of pride given the
scientific orientation of the family but
also feared and I was gonna either burn
myself up or or blow up the house or
whatever
you